bonjour merci de nous rejoindre dont fit
l'écho des missions qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale
on commence tout de suite avec les
titres de cette édition un long câble
pendant les vacances le fameux salon du
chocolat cette année il fête ses 20 ans
nous avons rencontré les entreprises
chinoises présentes pour cette édition
le droit à la formation dif elle
n'existe plus il sera remplacé à compter
de janvier 2015 par le compte personnel
des formations nous verrons les
changements en perspective pour les
salariés et les entreprises
enfin nous irons à la découverte de la
découverte de l'or rouge dans les
yvelines l'entreprise de la semaine
d'avis qu elle cultive une des plus
précieux des pis le safran enfin nous
reviendrons en grand dans notre
entretien sur le droit à la formation
individuelle il va prendre fin et sera
remplacé par le compte personnel de
formation en 2015 ce changement fait du
salarié l'acteur principal est le
décideur de sa formation
nous en parlerons dans quelques instants
avec rémy adore bonjour vous êtes
conseiller opcalia organisme partenaire
de l'emploi et de la formation les avons
notre entretien passons en revue
l'actualité de la semaine
le salon du chocolat fête ses 20 ans
cette année c'est un événement inratable
des vacances les français sont de grands
amateurs de chocolat il on consommerait
6 kg par an et par personne
violaine treize éoliennes et william
elle pardon se sont rendus au salon à la
rencontre de deux entreprises chinoises
qui vous allez le voir se démarque des
traditionnelles chocolaterie
au parc des expositions porte de
versailles le salaud vient d'ouvrir ses
portes au grand public et les visiteurs
sont déjà au rendez vous vous versez le
chocolat à l'intérieur vous le mettez au
frigo le retourner les chocolats tombe
le chocolat ne n'adhère pas si vous
voulez aux parois cette entreprise basée
à conflans sainte honorine depuis trois
ans est le tout premier salon du
chocolat
ils ont dépensé plus de 3000 euros pour
être ici et se faire connaître
spécialisé dans la pâtisserie
décoratives et créative la société
propose toute une gamme de matériels
professionnels des emporte-pièces des
moules des caissettes mais aussi des
produits alimentaires on dispose de
notre propre marque de pâte à sucre donc
la pâte à sucre en fait c'est comme de
la pâte à modeler ses comestibles et ça
sert à décorer des gâteaux donc on peut
réaliser plusieurs types de gâteaux par
exemple la princesse la poupée que vous
voyez là qui est réalisé donc sur une
base d'un gâteau comestibles et on
l'habille ensuite avec ce produit là la
société dispose donc de son propre
magasin mais propose également des
ateliers pratiques pour enfants et
adultes
vous n'êtes pas loin comme ça si vous
voulez passer neuf heures d'accord voilà
oui merci vous aussi faire plaisir
alors vas à quelques mètres de là une
autre société yvelinoise ici pas de
stands mais l'un des rares food truck du
salon un véhicule rétro qui attire et se
démarque
on propose des yaourts bio vous la fais
donc on a actuellement fait du yaourt
nature
on descend de salon du chocolat est bon
on propose divers au chocolat ou ma
éventuellement d'autres parfums à ce
rêve un bon vanille pour cette toute
jeune entreprise née il y a un an à
cheval à l'objectif est avant tout de se
faire connaître et d'aller vers les
passants bonjour voulez goûter c'est
gratuit le salon du chocolat se poursuit
jusqu'à dimanche et ne devrait pas
manquer d'amateurs au cours de l'année
2013 pour la première fois plus de 4
millions de tonnes de cacao aurait été
consommée dans le monde
32 % de plus qu'il ya dix ans une zone
d'aménagement concerté va être créée sur
le secteur beau bassin louise michel à
trappes
ce n'est que les prémisses cette zone
sera active d'ici plusieurs années
d'une surface de 21 hectares le site
pourrait devenir un pôle de
développement majeur intégré aux
contrats de développement territorial
des yvelines le quartier devra
accueillir des logements mais aussi des
commerces ainsi que des activités
tertiaires
écoutez ces précisions de jean marie le
merlu directeur adjoint de l'aménagement
de l'établissement public du plateau de
saclay dans l'opération d'aménagement
comme au visage on a réservé 30 mètres
carrés dédiés pour des locaux
d'activité d'entreprises petites
moyennes ou grandes
pour le moment on commence les études
donc on ne sait pas exactement comment
ça va comment ça va se traduire mais on
a réservé ce potentiel
un coup de pouce à l'emploi c'est le
dispositif lancé par la mairie de
verrières de la verrière pardon c'est un
dispositif de soutien à la formation et
à la création d'entreprise pour les
jeunes de 16 à 30 ans il est associé au
service jeunesse de la mairie
les projets seront choisis sur dossier
puis passeront devant une commission les
dossiers sélectionnés obtiendront 1000
euros ou seront financés à hauteur de
50%
une vingtaine de jeunes devraient
bénéficier de ce coup de pouce le coup
de pouce un fonds d'initiative
c'est un fonds d'initiatives par les
entreprises partenaires avec la ville
nous avons bouygues mgen rovia qui
financent eux font on attend des
réponses d'autres entreprises qu'on a
sollicité et eux s'engagent à être
partenaire avec nous de ces projets et
aussi de parrainer justement c'est cgem
et c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
employés de l'entreprise psa poissy 98
emplois sont supprimés dans l'équipe de
nuit sur les lignes d'emboutissage les
employés n'ont pas été surpris car cette
décision fait partie d'un plan de
réorganisation qui avait été annoncé
auparavant par psa aujourd'hui
l'entreprise de poissy produits deux
cent soixante mille véhicules en 2010
est seulement 140 milles devrait y être
assemblés
depuis lundi la production est arrêtée
pour une semaine faute de commandes
les contrats de 700 intérimaires ne
seront pas reconduits je vous propose de
passer maintenant à notre entretien de
la semaine
dans notre tient de la semaine nous
avons parlé du droit à la formation
individuelle si important pour les
salariés et pourtant méconnu nous
accueillons rémy adore qui je le
rappelle est conseillé ile de france
chez ocalia partenaire actif de la
politique de l'emploi est aussi
organismes de formation c'est ça non pas
du tout l'organisme au maximum en galice
paritaire collecteur agréé donc on est
payé par l'état pour gérer les fonds de
la formation professionnelle continue
il ya merci de cette précision donc
avant de commencer notre entretien je
vous propose de voir un reportage
réalisé ce matin de nombreux chefs
d'entreprise mais aussi des formateurs
iggy noah se sont rendus à la maison de
l'emploi et de la et de la formation
attrape une réunion était organisée par
plate par la plateforme rh pour les
informer de ces changements qui en
inquiète plus d'un attentif chacun prend
des notes
formateur chef d'entreprise ressources
humaines pour chacun d'entre eux la fin
du dif c'est un gros changement
le salarié devient l'acteur principal de
sa formation à partir de janvier 2015 on
va acquérir 24 heures par an pendant
cinq ans et ensuite deux heures par an
pendant deux ans et demi ce qui fait 150
heures au bout de sept ans et demi
l'objectif du gouvernement est de mettre
en avant les formations qualifiantes
certifiante ou diplômantes
pour celles qui sont éligibles les
critères sont plus strictes - de
formation financées c'est le principal
objet d'inquiétude
on a un peu dans les trucs papier par
rapport à ce financement des formations
qui peuvent être très intéressantes très
importante pour certains salariés mais
qui ne seront peut-être plus financé en
tout cas par l'employeur et dont
peut-être abandonné beaucoup craignent
de voir les possibilités de formation
diminuée avec ce changement
pourtant le système créé en 2004 n'a
jamais remporté un franc succès si en
2009 seules six ont mille personnes
environ 6% des salariés avaient déjà
profité du droit à la formation
individuelle en 2012 47% ne l'avait
toujours pas utilisé par manque
d'information d'intérêt ou simplement
car ils ne savaient pas quelle formation
suivre alors vous l'avez vu le droit à
la formation un défi diète invitée elle
va être remplacé en janvier 2015 par le
cf pf le compte personnel de formation
pour commencer rim et adore pourquoi le
droit à la formation divisée at il été
remplacé après ce changement
voit bien dans le reportage il a été peu
consommés par sa mauvaise communication
qui a eu autour de ce dif ce soit par
les pouvoirs publics comme par par les
employeurs donc l'idée c'était de fondre
un peu le système et c'est vrai que le
cpf intervient aussi lors de la réforme
de la formation professionnelle continue
donc qui donc y est acté un par une loi
depuis le 5 mars donc du 5 mars 2014
donc 7
ce changement de différents cpf
intervient en même temps que cette
réforme qui voilà qui révolutionne le
système de la formation telle qu'elle
était depuis plus de 30 ans la corde
comme comme on l'a vu dans le reportage
donc le salarié et tout et tout coeur
c'est l'acteur principal de sa formation
en d'autres temps qu'est-ce que ça va
changer pour lui et aussi pour son
employeur
alors pour lui ça va lui donner plus de
liberté donc on va rester positif par
rapport aux inquiétudes du reportage
c'est vrai que le salarié aura cette
liberté donc de pouvoir faire une
formation dans le cadre du cpf hors
temps de travail alors que c'est vrai
qu'auparavant cela n'était pas possible
il fallait toujours l'accord de son
employeur pour pouvoir mettre en place à
sa formation
donc là il ya une liberté pour le
salarié qui n'avait pas auparavant
il devra quand même demandé en sont
encore à un employeur alors jours à
l'accord avec l'employeur perdure si la
formation et dans le temps de travail ou
s'ils souhaitent que l'employeur abonde
un financement complémentaire sur la
formation qui va suivre hors temps de
travail mais en tout cas la liberté de
faire sa formation hors temps de travail
sans en parler à son employeur et laura
le financement de l'opca parce que ce
que nous sommes au titre du cpm alors
pour assurer un cas les chefs
d'entreprises ainsi que du coup ils sont
un peu dépossédé de l'ordre ils peuvent
plus peut-être proposer des formations
on imposer enfin comment ça va se passer
bush justement pour les employeurs pour
les employeurs
il faut pas oublier qu'ils ont toujours
leur plan de formation donc pour l'heure
leurs collaborateurs dont qu'ils auront
toujours arbitré les formations qui se
souhaite mettre en oeuvre dans leur
année pendant l'année après le cpf pour
être mobilisés comme le dif si les
collaborateurs souhaitent bien sûr
engagé alors cpf sur la formation parce
que le cpf tout comme pour le dif
il fallait qu'ils aient un accord écrit
entre l'employeur et le salarié sur
l'utilisation de ces droits donc ça ça
perdure a toujours on l'a vu dans le
reportage sont les formations
certifiantes et diplômantes terrifiante
qui sont mis en avant
alors qu'est ce que ça signifie ce
tintin peut compléter alors ça signifie
plein de choses c'est là que c'est là où
il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes valade et
de tout le monde de tous les acteurs de
la formation
donc il va avoir plusieurs listes qui
vont déterminer en fait des actions de
formations éligibles
on en connaît déjà certaines donc on
sait qu est la liste du répertoire nasa
parmi le répertoire national des
certifications professionnelles rncp
donc c'est tout les tous les titres
diplôme donc ont été déposés sur ce
répertoire
on va avoir l'inventaire de la
commission national des certifications
professionnelles également qui doit donc
qui doit des gens qui doit avoir une
liste des tabliers qui n'est pas encore
fait pour le moment où ce sera plus des
formations dites transversales qu'on
pourra retrouver sur différents métiers
donc cette liste doit de cette étape
établi et on attend aussi des listes une
liste la liste donc interprofession
nationale interprofessionnelle qui va
déterminer après de toutes les autres
listes régionales et aussi auprès des
branches
est-ce que ça avec eux
pour expliquer ce que nous sommes les
opca donc il ya des opca
interprofessionnels et donc des
organismes qui sont rattachés enfin des
entreprises sont sur les opca interpro
ne sont pas rattachées à une branche
collective excusez moi et il ya des
entreprises qui sont rattachés à une
branche donc collective à une convention
collective pardon et donc qu'ils vont
adhérer un autre cadre de branche et
donc c'est il faut bien différencier les
deux et c'est vrai que les la branche et
l'interpro on a négocié des listes de
formation pour pour que l'on puisse
avoir le choix des formations d'egypte
de cpf et pour les formations qui n'ont
pas de disposer d'un diplôme
par exemple vous voyez une dame
s'exprimer dans le reportage cette
entreprise
elle a une entreprise d'abdallah
personnes des femmes de ménage il n'y a
pas de diplôme là dessus il reste de
monde voilà quelle formation
elle va pouvoir leur offrir de que ça va
pas être financés pour ces formations
qui ne sont pas voilà bien un diplôme
sait comment ça va se passer ça va être
un petit peu compliqué peut-être à
financer alors il y aura toujours la
partie plan de formation c'est à dire le
budget qu'il souhaitera mettre sur la
formation de ses collaborateurs
après est ce peut si on est sur la
branche des services à la personne
il se peut que l'opca de branche donc
qui n'est pas opcalia va déterminer
d'une liste qui donc
correspond aux besoins de formation des
entreprises de cette branche
donc il se peut que l'on retrouve les
formations qu'elle recherche
et on ne les connaît pas en quoi c'est
tout et a négocié par les partenaires
sociaux fin les représentants de chacune
des branches qui existent donc comment
les entreprises vont pas le faire si
justement elles veulent voilà payer
offrir alors à leurs employés ces
formations qui ne sont pas nés comme
c'est vraiment à lèvres devoir mettre la
main à la poche
au final alors c'est vrai que faut pas
oublier que le compte personnel de
formation c'est une démarche
individuelle ça appartient vraiment aux
salariés fas l'individu donc donc ça
appartient pas à l'entreprise donc c'est
si le collaborateur souhaite engager son
cpu en cadre du plan de formation de sa
société oui là c'est possible après si
donc la formation se souhaite mettre en
oeuvre
l'entreprise n'est pas l'egypte au cpf
etc sont et que du coup il n'y a pas
d'accord à avoir sur du collaborateur
pour cette formation
effectivement il va falloir qu'elle le
financent sur son plan de formation et
pur donc donc à partir de 2015 donc le
dif va se transformer pour les heures de
droit à la formation individuelle à cul
mais qu'est ce qui va se passer du coup
est-ce que c'est perdu
non alors s'est pas perdue donc elles
vont être transférable au titre du cpf à
partir du 1er janvier
donc on pourra les utiliser donc les
mobilisés au titre du cp est vraiment
dans les conditions du cpf est plus dans
les conditions du dif et il faut pas
oublier va surtout des employeurs ne
doivent pas oublier de communiquer
auprès de leurs salariés avant le 31
janvier 2015 de leurs droits au dif
acquis au 31 décembre 2014
je vous proposerai me adore de regarder
avec nous la question de la semaine nous
vous a demandé à vous yvelinois si vous
connaissiez le droit à l'information
individuelle et c'est ce dont vous aviez
bénéficier tendu par du poisson plus je
connais parce que je suis un peu dans le
métier tu dans les ressources humaines
donc je sais à quoi ça correspond
mais jusqu'à présent je n'ai pas besoin
moi je connais pas du tout ça permet aux
employés de trouver une nouvelle voie de
permettre de se former dans les heures
de travail et avec le soutien
d'entreprises le dise je connais parce
qu'effectivement fonds sont des
démarches pour des personnes qui
changent de métier commun de formation
j'ai entendu de bons échos mais moi je
n'ai pas eu l'occasion d'utiliser je
connais parce que je suis actuellement
j'ai fait une des manches sur internet
mais intermittents du spectacle j'ai
demandé à pouvoir faire une formation
par le dif
finalement la formation je voulais un
correspondait pas en nombre d'or dans la
semaine obligatoire à faire minimum donc
je suis passé sur un cif
donc oui je connais le dif et je connais
ici alors nous l'avons vu le dif est
méconnu peu de gens en ont bénéficié
est ce que l'on pensait que le compte
personnel de formation va avoir le même
destin
j'espère pas je pense que on va tous
tous les acteurs de la formation vont
vont se mobiliser pour en tout cas bien
informée donc les entreprises et les
salariés
je pense qu'il est prévu en tout cas une
communication à grand public de la part
du ministère de l'emploi fin du travail
de l'emploi et de la formation
donc après nous c'est vrai que nous n'en
parle en entreprise
tous les jours quand nous sommes au
rendez vous les organismes de formation
aussi acteur bas sont aussi mobilisés
pour pour en parler et faire en sorte
que tout le monde comprenne bien le
nouveau fonctionnement et que et que
tout le monde mobilisent leurs cpf et il
faut savoir aussi au niveau de
l'information
on aura tous chaque individu un compte
donc dématérialisé qui sera géré par la
caisse des dépôts et consignations donc
on aura nos identifiant on pourra s'y
connecter pour voir le nombre le crédit
d'heures de ses pairs que nous avons
ainsi que toutes les listes des
formations dites éligibles donc l'idée
c'est quand même que l'individu puisse
se connecter directement
du coup sans passer par son employeur
donc l'information elle est vraiment
direct donc je pense que ça devrait
fonctionner et en parlant justement
d'information il me semble que vous
organisez bientôt un nouveau rendez vous
pour ceux qui souhaitent en savoir plus
oui effectivement alors avec en
partenariat avec la cité des métiers de
saint quentin en yvelines
on organise le 27 novembre donc dans
l'après midi donc une rencontre autour
de la réforme parce que comme je vous
disais le cpf n'est qu'une partie de la
grande réforme de la formation
professionnelle continue donc ce sera
l'occasion de discuter de ce changement
qui s'opère pour à partir du 1er janvier
merci beaucoup rémy adore d'être venu
sur notre plateau si vous désirez plus
d'informations pouvez vous rendre sur le
site
opcalia points comme nous poursuivons
maintenant notre émission avec le
chiffre de la semaine
1,8 c'est le pourcentage de demandeurs
d'emploi en plus pour le mois de
septembre dans les yvelines
la semaine dernière le pôle emploi pôle
emploi publiés les chiffres du chômage
pour le mois de septembre 2014 pour la
catégorie à c'est-à-dire les personnes
sans aucune activité
cela représente environ un millier de
chômeurs en plus par rapport au mois
d'août sur notre département on dénombre
donc 70 1190 chômeurs dans les yvelines
en un an le chômage a donc augmenté de
6,9 pour cent à savoir qu'en
ile-de-france ce pourcentage est de 6,2
pour cent
je vous propose maintenant de découvrir
le métier de la semaine
cette semaine nous intéressons aux
métiers de la mort vous savez c'est
bientôt la toussaint à cette occasion
nous avons voulu en savoir un peu plus
sur les métiers des pompes funèbres qui
peine à recruter conseiller funéraire
une profession méconnue qui n'a pas
souvent une bonne image mais c'est
pourtant essentielle pour les familles
qui traversent un deuil des images
signées elodie moines une atmosphère
paisible le recueillement règne pour la
toussaint
mais pour les pompes funèbres c'est le
jour le plus chargé de l'année
ce qu'il faudrait c'est les petits pots
pour fluidifier remettre le gravier
par-dessus nan moi c'est ce que je
conseille toujours leur plaque l
approche de la fête des défunts
les conseillers funéraires sont très
sollicités l'a exceptionnellement d'un
des fleurs naturelles qu'on vend
uniquement pour la toussaint
donc on a depuis une dizaine de jours
jusqu'à mardi prochain à peu près et on
sera tous les trois là pour un kayak des
personnes qui veulent aller se
recueillir sur les monuments de la
pierre tombale au cercueil
le conseiller funéraire guide les
familles dans le déroulement de la
cérémonie
plus de 500 milles obsèques ont lieu en
2013 pour cette même année l'insee
recense 3457 entreprise de pompes
funèbres dans l'hexagone dont 117 dans
les yvelines à versailles
ils vont à la bière entré comme porteur
il ya neuf ans est maintenant conseiller
funéraire
il apporte son aide à tous vous avez des
gens et ça nous arrivait déjà qu'une
personne rentrent en disant monsieur je
souhaite ce ce cercueil pourquoi les
pousses du monsieur travailler le bois
et elle travaille et se boit
donc il n'a pas réfléchi il faut savoir
que chez nous il ya deux parties a quand
même une partie accueil relations
humaines organisation et faut pas cacher
aussi une partie commerciale
parce que chez nous les joueurs on fait
tout nous avons pas de produits et
toutes à la première chose c'est cette
relation humaine avec les gens
commerciaux organisateurs administratif
le métier à plusieurs facettes une
formation d'un an post baccalauréat
dispense en 200 heures environ les
rudiments du métier à côté les
conseillers en devenir ont une formation
pratique en agence
la psychologie et le contact avec les
familles est essentielle pour
appréhender chaque situation
chaque décès est complètement différent
tout dépend après des personnes qui vous
fait face à soi pour une personne d'un
certain âge pour que ce soit un enfant
un ado même si la relation humaine est
là pour l'organisation puisque nous
sommes à l'écouté des familles nous
organisons comme elles le veulent bien
entendu mais avant toute chose il ya un
petit recul quand même l'europe avec les
femmes il est entendu à 20% des
vingt-cinq mille salariés travaillant
dans les pompes funèbres sont
déconseillés funéraire le secteur attire
peu pourtant ils recrutent dans les
pompes funèbres
un tiers des embauches relève d'une
création de poste passons maintenant à
tout autre sujet avec l'entreprise de la
scène
l'entreprise de la semaine vient tout
juste de se créer elle pourrait
rapporter beaucoup d'ici plusieurs
années
sa propriétaire installé à vic cultive
ce qu'on appelle leur rouge
le safran une discipline une des épices
les plus chères au monde
trente mille euros le kilo un reportage
de catherine du gâteau ghislaine thorez
et william l avec son panier en osier
aurélie jacques parent à la cueillette
non pas des champignons ces deux saisons
mais du safran une des épices les plus
chères au monde qui se cultive en pleine
terre là vous avez la première parcelle
que j'ai planté l'année dernière qui
représente à peu près cette année dix
mille bulles
donc elle a déjà beaucoup fleury là on
est en fin de récolte donc il reste
quelques fleurs les fleurs de crocus
sont cueillies le matin car elles
sortent la nuit
elles sont ensuite mondes et pour isoler
le pistil rouge qui est la fameuse
épices le pistil doit être immédiatement
sécher une fois qu'il aura perdu 80% de
son poids il pourra être mis en pot sur
les parcours bien ses partisans à venir
cette année aurait dit jacques accueilli
27 mille fleurs 15000 bulbes
supplémentaires ont été plantés autant
de plantation pour une production de 300
grammes seulement de safran et pour
obtenir ces quelques grammes
beaucoup de travail on plante tout à la
main donc on est obligé de faire une
tranchée avec un outil qui s'appelle une
houe et après on plante à la main à
genoux on rebouche ont fait des allées
avec une pelle donc déjà c'est assez
physique et après il ya le désherbage
qui se fait aussi à la main donc moi je
ne porte pas de pesticides et autres le
safran aurait dit jacques l'a découvert
un peu par hasard en 2008 ses parents
agriculteurs décident de prendre leur
retraite se pose la question de la
reprise de l'exploitation céréalière
familiale un voisin vient donner un coup
de main aurélie imagine de créer elle
même ses productions et apprend que le
safran pouces en france en 2012
j'ai fait un stage chez véronique
lazerat qui a la plus grande salle
fragnière de france et puis je me suis
lancé dans l'aventuré
j'avais fait un premier test en plantant
mille bulbes et en 2012 l'année dernière
j'en ai planté à peu près 5000 et puis
cette année j'en ai rappelé implique un
mille de plus au total
j'en ai
la culture du safran c'est loin loin de
l'univers d'aurélie la jeune femme
travaille dans la finance pour une
société de gestion d'actifs
toute une organisation au moment de la
récolte comme fauqué lien les fleurs le
matin j allais avons travaillé donc
j'y allais avec une lampe frontale pour
cueillir les fleurs et puis après
j'avais travaillé ma deuxième journée à
paris cette année aurélie jacques a
vendu ses premiers grammes de safran
pour l'heure c'est juste une
diversification de l'exploitation
agricole
mais à terme pourquoi pas une vraie
petite entreprise qui pourrait
s'annoncer très rentable car le safran
se monnaye 30000 euros le kilo il faut
entre 150 milles et 200 mille fleurs
pour en faire un kilo avec un gramme de
safran vous pouvez déjà parfumé entre 50
et 150 assiette un gramme de safran
vendus par aurélie 34 euros en france il
n'y a que 150 cette exploitation de
safran pour une production nationale qui
est aussi entre 250 et 300 kg alors que
les leaders eux en iran produisent entre
160 et 180 tonnes à l'année
cela laisse donc entrevoir de belles
perspectives économiques
il est maintenant temps de passer à
l'agenda de la scène
et cette semaine de rendez vous à ne pas
manquer le mardi 4 novembre de 18h30 à
22h le réseau coaction ce sont 18
organise en partenariat avec la poste et
la société générale sa rencontre inter
associations au château de maisons
laffitte
l'objectif est de favoriser les échanges
les partages d'expériences les
meilleures pratiques sur des enjeux
communs à la fois entre associations
mais aussi entre membres pour s'inscrire
rapprochez-vous de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de versailles
yvelines la cité des métiers de trappes
organise vendredi 7 novembre un atelier
sur l'importance de l'apparence dans la
vie sociale et professionnelle de 9h30 à
11h30 venez découvrir avec un coach en
image les astuces et conseils pour vous
mettre en valeur construire votre
garde-robe professionnels en fonction de
votre style et de votre métier
n'oubliez pas de vous inscrire merci de
nous avoir suivis c'est la fin de notre
de notre émission pardon je vous donne
rendez vous la semaine prochaine
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée